if you're on a fitness journey well yeah
you can you couldn't tell that from my
outfit today I think you look great
well I've gained a lot of weight so I've
not seen you for a while
no ass and since you've seen me I gained
15 pounds 15 April a scale and I aren't
good friends right now because that
frickin thing keeps going up first of
all I'd like to say there are a lot of
haters out there that say oh it's
because she's so upset and her marriage
is doing well
this is happy Pat this is fat that comes
about when you eat whatever you want
we're going out to eat with your husband
and your family and when you have a few
cocktails this is what happens so I am
working with dr. Tim who was on the show
last season with me and we were doing
our doing Facebook live video right
three times a week and they're you know
they're not crazy hard but we're gonna
get there I've got a reunion to film in
October
that's my d-day to get better to get
slimmer again and I will
what's the number ox now highest I've
ever been in my life 148 148 plate
what's the body cut one forty eight
point eight thirty two point six we can
only go down from here baby
it's nice because a lot of people watch
live and they ask questions and this or
that and the last time we did it people
were saying I've lost eight pounds I've
lost 10 pounds of us 17 pounds is crazy
I think I've lost 1 pound but I've lost
7 percent body fat
hey getting muscle over here trying to
now but not like camera muscle I just
know I just want to get toned that's it
cheers to that
got cheers Cheers cuz you know great to
have a cocktail with you tell ya that
locale it's all clear liquid
you